hey guys it is Thursday the 13th the far
less threatening cousin a Friday the
13th my name is Jeff and you're watching
us but new Xbox bosqueville Spencer
shared some thoughts about what the
company has in store for backwards
compatibility when asked on Twitter
whether call duty black ops 2 would be
added to the catalog he replied I like
the progress on backwards compatibility
we'd like to have all and work on
third-party games is always the
partnership with publisher so not much
of an answer on black ops 2 there but
Microsoft have been consistently adding
new games that so fingers crossed black
ops 2 is currently the most requested
game for inclusion in the catalog on the
Xbox feedback site with more than one
hundred and ninety three thousand votes
microsoft announced today that silent
hill downpour eat lead the return of
matt hazard and puzzle quest challenge
of the warlords are all now backwards
compatible next up Sony might owe you
money over a ps3 issue in 2010 a
class-action lawsuit was filed against
Sony who originally claimed that you
would be able to install Linux on the
ps3 when they later locked out other OS
support people weren't too pleased the
publisher has since opted to settle this
year and now those in the US can claim
up to 55 bucks from Sony to get paid
you'll need to supply proof of purchase
feel fat ps3 purchase between november
of 2006 and april 2010 as well as
provide proof of use of other OS
features console owners can also get a
grand nine dollars by proving they
bought a ps3 and a test that they
intended to use the other OS
functionality there is still a final
approval hearing for the settlement
package so you might still have many
months to wait before you get your hands
on that nine bucks finally PlayStation
VR is able to display video from the ps4
as well as a number of other platforms
using cinematic mode it's not so much
the full VR experience but you will be
able to play your ps4 pc and xbox one
games on a giant virtual screen should
that take your fancy the external
processing unit for the headset can
output video to both the headset and TV
simultaneously of course you can swap
out your ps4 for something else like an
Xbox one or we
you and have that output to your headset
instead gamespot tried this one out and
couldn't find a way to recenter the
camera while not using the ps4 but it
does seem to be an option to use other
platforms PS vr is out today be sure to
head to game [ __ ] for stories on tyranny
and call of duty infinite warfare and
I'll be back with my top 5 stories of
the week tomorrow